The joe rogan experience.
Fairly Lockhart,
by the way.
A used to be on the Frank Kelly endo shown is,
in my opinion,
one of the best impression is out there.
You,
you do impressions that are very weird man.
You do some impressions that no one else does.
That's the,
I figured that that's what you should do.
I always figured it's like,
why get in and do something?
The Nicholson,
the ones like that,
it's like I try to find a strange one and I do it like [inaudible] man,
don't nobody do it.
Bunch of bitches.
I do it better than I to t man,
not to his voiceover work and whatnot.
I love to say what not do you know at the Lisbon everything?
I tried to make a little list there and he fights a little lift,
but it's kind of gangster and it works for him.
You know what I'm saying?
Pitch us,
dig it.
I used to do that at the comedy store.
I used to call the comedy store is ice tea in this poor guy,
Kenny Tenney.
This guy used to work the phones there.
Do you remember this guy?
He was Mitsis Pool Guy and there was something,
something was off with him.
Definitely say,
I mean,
I don't want to say what he had,
but he definitely wasn't one of us.
You know,
he wasn't thinking right,
but he was,
he was like,
he got,
he made money.
He,
he had a pool company,
he cleaned pulls and he did it well,
but he'd function like an eight year old and a,
I would call him every time he would pick up the phone,
I would call them and I would be ice tea and he would fall for it every time.
But like,
Yo man,
I'm bringing 30 people in tonight,
man.
What you got on my booth that you would
like?
I Miss Jay,
we don't have a booth at six 30 I'm like,
you better build one for me.
Well I'll see if we can,
I'm just like,
ah.
That's how I would brush up on the impression as if I could pull Kenny Turney.
I felt like it was golden.
Yeah.
How do you,
do you work impressions of you practice them at home and then eventually bring
them this stage or do you know when you hear somebody whether or not you can do
it?
You know,
I,
there's a lot of people,
if you hear them right away,
I know I can do it.
If somebody that tends to have a deeper voice or something like that or if
there's a weird thing about them,
I know I can do it,
but I always more so than the way it sounds,
it's the way somebody looks when they talk because people move their mouth a
certain way that will reveal half the impression.
You know,
I just realized talking to you about impressions,
you know,
I don't,
I've never practiced any of the impressions that I've done.
I just do them like with Joey Diaz or something like that.
I just know I can do it and I just do it.
Do you,
are you that way too?
Like you hear someone talk?
Yeah.
I think it's like you got to get out of your own way.
You've just let it filter in and come out.
Come out of here,
you know,
cause it's like,
like you'll hear it if you should try to scrutinize it,
you'll really start to fuck it up.
But
you know,
I'll,
I'll listen to them on headphones and if I don't hear my voice anymore and that
means I've matched it,
wo it means I've matched it.
It looks like the Morgan Freeman when I started working on an eighth grade,
I'm here that way.
I now hold on Joe Rogan.
Let me get to that.
Let's see here.
There's a fella named Morgan Freeman and I started working on the impression
when I was in the eighth grade.
Yes sir.
I was about 14 years old,
jerked off seven times a day.
She's had,
it's creepy and it took me forever.
What happens,
creep.
And the way I finally perfected it,
when I was like 22 I saw Ben Affleck on,
on,
um,
Dave Letterman.
And he was doing it a Morgan Freeman impression,
but it was horrible.
But he was doing one thing.
I wasn't doing it right.
It's that thing.
It's all in here.
He was adding that everything else was wrong.
And I married the two and I was talking like Morgan Freeman all day.
I was calling restaurants,
but like I'd like to get a table for two planes and was like,
okay,
Mr. Freeman.
I was testing it out and I was like,
oh my God,
amazing.
So when I nail one,
I've been working on a Tom Hanks for years and I still can't get it.
There's something,
but he's one of those like ice tea,
like Morgan Freeman.
Everybody knows who he is,
but nobody does.
And you know it's somewhere in here.
I found that I can,
I can go back and forth with it,
but it's,
it's,
you miss it a little.
Yeah.
I'm game show hosts d with it right now,
but it's like there's,
there's World War II,
Tom Hanks who's very solemn and talks about World War II,
but then there's,
you know,
I'm on Conan O'brien.
The shape of your head is wrong,
but I can't make that noise.
I think that is,
I think that has lots to do with impressions because there's certain impressions
that I can do that other people can't do.
Right.
I think it's the shape of my face.
There's money,
there's ways to manipulate your throat.
I mean,
luck until he was told to book the Slo.
Definitely.
You know,
you can move contort your mouth like biggie smalls.
That's totally working on little personal one time too.
And I found out how to sound like a fuck La.
It's like you can contort your mouth.
You Ralphie May.
He's
much love Ralphie.
If you listening,
you know we love you.
He said Cartman on those.
I don't know what happens when you get an office,
but clearly someone sits you down and just your agenda talking about before he
was in office,
you know,
you're sorry.
Inhaled well you could say,
cause it was the point you doing a Bama well it's a,
it's time for weed.
I uh,
it's like pauses the twin,
every word I say.
So the stupid people can understand me.
Uh,
no.
Did you?
Oh,
in college sir,
uh,
I did you inhale?
I took bong rips out of a homemade bomb and I blew them.
And to everybody on the floors,
mouth,
we got a high,
that's the place that the site is still bill still bill.
One of the best documentaries I've seen in pro Bobby Lee's recommendation.
Funny enough.
Wow.
And not funny enough because sometimes he recommends really good stuff,
but other times he recommends horrible.
It's the worst thing he's ever recommended.
Uh,
the,
um,
the whatcha call it movie with a river Phoenix,
his brother.
Uh Oh yeah,
I heard there was terrible.
It was awful.
He thought it was brilliant.
Really.
And it's fucking brilliant.
Fucking brilliant book.
Lovey leave.
It's brilliant.
It wasn't brilliant.
A lot of his stuff.
He bought impressions.
Bobby's into good,
pretty good movies.
And you do Bobby Lee.
Can you do,
I can do fucking Bobby Lee.
I've been a fucking bomb.
Joe Rogan.
I'm gonna fucking bomb.
And they walked in pretty close.
Yeah.
Close as much as he knew Jesse Ventura.
Jesse the body.
Ventura.
That's vow.
It's Jesse Ventura.
That's for,
come on Joe.
Rogan's to talk the truth.
Yeah,
that's good.
I think I got pretty,
God damn good.
I've never done that before.
Nine one one was an inside job.
If you think the ladder,
you're the one who's missing four brother,
you don't think that Rumsfeld knew what we was doing when he told those troops
to stand down.
Niche almost sounds a little Sam Elliott in there too,
a little bit.
Raj Realm.
If you don't get any roadhouse quotes in,
you show that man to the door and if he doesn't go quietly,
what does it use this truck and head and by yourself at dodge ram pickup with
all the torque and you definitely know how to stretch his words out.
The waist turns his words and rocky get on the bike.
Rocky.
Dennis,
what was that thing you did about ice,
tea and cocoa?
What did you do recently?
Ah,
triply show.
Uh,
maybe ball baby pool.
Yeah,
we did an ice tea commercial with,
with a coco.
Great Cocoa Look alike my way.
Did she look just like,
oh,
go for it.
She was built like her.
She was an anomaly like this huge ass.
Huge boobs and this tiny waist.
Now granted it was all sculpted that way,
but it was still this anomaly.
It was like,
whoa.
It was ridiculous.
Sculptors meaning like operations,
operations at top.
I've heard people saying that Coco and my wife said she's absolutely beautiful.
I I um,
but uh,
yeah,
we did the ice tea thing.
We did the baby bull man.
That went over pretty well and he saw it.
Red Band tweeted it.
Yeah.
An ice tea tweeted back.
What did it say?
What did he say?
I said a,
uh,
I made a video.
What do you think about this?
And he might say it's interesting.
I'd say that's pretty God damn good iced tea.
That's that I,
that's man,
that's dead.
That's 100%.
And I'm fighting off a cold from the past three days.
Sometimes I want to have a cold.
My impressions to get a little better.
Like I've never done that Ventura one before.
I didn't know that.
Really do a good bro call.
I left on good bro.
Jamie off [inaudible]
shooters,
bombs are falling and draw all of iron.
Did you know Tom Brokaw was a pothead 24 hour day plan?
Is He really prideful pot?
I take wrong reps on a daily.
I only smoking indycar.
I the shit hero makes me not want to do my job.
That's hilarious.
That's so good guy nuts.
He really does smoke.
Where'd you hear this?
You know,
I read it somewhere and I just ran with it.
I didn't research that I was looking at school.
Go Do.
Uh,
just see I say Tom a Tom.
Tom Rogue raw part her.
How do you spell broke?
Call Br.
Okay.
Batch boy.
Roger Ocean saw a family guy last night where there was like gang of Bro.
Cause there's like 12 of them.
Never did it.
Not Interested.
Where did was I experimented with a little marijuana.
I never really like a lot of other people.
You just made up some shit.
Dammit.
Somebody made it up and I wanted to believe it too.
I wish I didn't Google it.
Alright.
Who else?
Who's confirming is this,
is there,
is there some clearing house of,
of whether a celebrity's a pothead or not and broke hog and post if it's a trip
and working on a John Lithgow as well.
My girlfriend doesn't like it,
but I do actually.
She does like it.
Hello decks to more women.
Can you do Nancy Grace?
She's my favorite.
Nancy crates thick.
This is a real problem.
Ah,
uh,
Ted babies in Florida.
We are alive right now.
Who?
Me?
Yeah.
Oh,
there was a good march.
Was it?
The other one that you do that's amazing is a Morgan Freeman,
isn't it?
As Morgan Freon deaths for Dick.
And he do fray Andy Dufresne and gave me hand jobs those last few nights talking
about your penis.
Morgan.
Matt Penis hangs down to my knee caps and I'm wearing knickerbockers shorts.
You can tell.
Oh sure.
Why not to do lean on me quotes.
What you getting that lock us on my future.
All right now
and then I take quotes from,
from lean on me and I changed them around.
I can lean on me.
There's this kid he keeps hassling cause it's kids like,
Yo,
Mr Clock,
man,
I'm going to move away man.
I'm gonna go make money.
He's like,
you'll be dead in a yes on.
no,
no man,
I'm going to go work for my uncle.
But you dead in the year to be in a,
a buddy would take it and be like,
Yo,
Mr. Clark,
I got accepted to Harvard,
man,
you'll be dead in a yes on not going to Harvard and Cambridge.
You'll be dead in a yes.
Well,
fuck you then Clark.
Okay.